a while back when i used to be
interested in origami one of the things
i used to make a lot would be a paper
balloon
it's pretty cool you can blow it up and
uh you know it doesn't float around or
anything but
it's pretty neat to make so that's what
i'm going to show you how to do today
i also used to make ninja stars
and i used to make a series of them and
just connect them in this
one giant frisbee like thing
and that was also pretty cool so i might
teach you guys how to do that let me
know what you think of this tutorial
and i'll see about making that tutorial
also so today i'm going to teach you how
to make a paper balloon
and what you need is a piece of printer
paper
and a scissor the scissor however is
optional
if you want to do things without
scissors and you just you know want to
make the folds yourself you could do
that also you don't need the scissor
so the first thing you want to do is to
get a piece of printer paper and you're
going to make
one fold across like that
so you want to bring the corner of this
paper all the way
until it meets the left edge of the of
the paper
and you want to fold it so that this is
flat you want this to be perfectly lined
up you don't want to be hanging over
like that
so we're going to fold it
all right so that's pretty lined up now
what you want to do is you want to cut
off this excess that you have here
if you did want to fold it and rip it
off that would be fine
but i'm going to cut it just for
simplification in the tutorial
so you want to cut off this little extra
ledge here
all right so you can throw that away and
what you have here now
if you open it you'll see it's a square
and it should measure eight inches by
eight inches
and as you'll see it already has that
one fold in it now
so now that it has that one fold in it
you want to take
so you can hold this fold going like
that and you want to take the corner of
this page and you want to make another
fold
that's perpendicular to this one so you
want to take this and you want to fold
it all the way
until it meets the edge
and then you want to make a crease like
that also
okay so now if you open it you should
have a square that has an
x in it now what you want to do
is you want to hold the x in front of
you and you want to take this paper
and you want to fold it in half just
like that
until this piece meets the other piece
the edge meets the edge
and now you want to make a crease like
that also
so just crease it and now you'll see if
you open it you should have an x
and a line going through the middle
okay so what you want to do now that you
have the x and the horizontal line is to
fold the paper in half
and you want to just make sure that that
crease is pretty good
lay the paper flat and what you want to
do now is you want to lift
this first layer up and you want to tuck
this corner in
so this corner is right here you want to
tuck it down
here all the way near my thumb
i want to tuck it in like that and then
you want to fold this flap
down and you want to make a crease in
the middle here on that new fold so then
we do the same thing with the other side
lift this first layer up and you
tuck this corner in
and then you just make a crease here
alright so just make the make sure the
whole thing is pretty flat
okay so what you should have now is you
should have something that looks like
this
uh just has these flaps here so you hold
it here so it looks like a triangle
an isosceles triangle and then you take
one flap here and you fold it up
so that the tip of this meets the top of
the triangle
and then you make a crease
do the same thing with the other side
and then flip the paper over and you do
the same exact thing
so you fold this up
fold this one up
and now you'll see you have a diamond
and each of these flaps should be folded
up just like that
now what you want to do is you want to
take remember there's two different
layers here
so you want to take the first layer and
you want to take these ends here
you want to take these ends and you want
to fold this piece
into the middle on this line
you want to fold it right like that
so you fold it like that
do the same thing for the other ones
flip it over
you don't have to be too need about it
doesn't really matter alright so you
should have something that looks like
this
and you should have two free flaps or
wings on the front and two free on the
back
so what you want to do now is you want
to tuck each of these wings
into these little pockets that are here
okay so to do that you take a flap
and you fold it straight down so that
the tip of this
is meeting the tip of this one
and you want to fold it straight down
just like that
then what you do is you fold it over
and then you could tuck it into that
pocket
so you just open it like that and you
tuck
the tip of that into the pocket and you
push it all the way in
and then you fold it down and then you
want to do that for the other three
so
and the last one fold it over
open the pocket tuck it in
and there you go you have a paper
balloon
all right so the balloons ready to be
inflated all you have to do is to flip
it over
and then if you open it by folding it
like that
what you'll see is that there is an
opening here
so what you have to do is just blow on
it and the bloom will be inflated
and it just takes one breath which is
the good thing about it and there you go
you have a paper balloon
so hope you guys enjoy the tutorial and
thanks for watching